I believe in modeling I believe success
leaves clues whatever problem is in
front of you in your business in your
relationships in your life your career
someone has already faced it
I already has solved it we knew so
little about the variety store vendors
that we had to take the book that was
written by Ben Franklin
and apply the principles rise and shine
it's in spresso time good morning
believe nation it's evan my one word is
believe and i believe in you i believe
you have an amazing gift inside to you
that i want to see exploded on to the
world so let's start your day off right
together grab your coffee and sip on
today's message model success over to
you tony robbins how did you go from
basically not having a hot meal to you
know basically being a guru an
international guru doling out financial
advice
well it's interesting I was just worth
magazine just named you there power 100
is 100 most influential people on global
finance along with Carl all the guys I
interviewed but part of it is I believe
in modeling I believe success leaves
clues if someone has done very well
financially for decade after decade
they're not lucky they're doing
something different if someone is fit
and healthy and they've managed it for
20 years they're like if they got a
great relationship they're not lucky so
I'm really good at deciphering what
those things are so I would go sit down
with someone like Jack Bogle you know a
little built you know 3 you know
trillion dollar history right you know
I'm what he's doing there Vanguard and
I'm supposed to have a 45-minute
interview we go for hours and he says
he's been in the business 65 years and
in the book he says it was the most
penetrating emotional delivery has ever
done his life because I kind of extract
it out of their brain and then make it
simple so you can apply whatever problem
you have right now someone has already
figured it out whatever problem is in
front of you in your business in your
relationships in your life your career
someone has already faced it and already
has solved it and it may have taken them
decades in some cases to solve it and
you can learn what they did apply it to
your situation and in
it's have a solution this is the
ultimate shortcut to success it's why I
need my channel my youtube channel
modeling the Masters because my goal was
to be able to model people who've done a
lot more than me and hopefully speed my
path forward and take you guys along my
journey with me I always say that Bill
Gates saved my company my first company
now I've never met Bill Gates he's still
alive I still may get my chance but I
never met Bill Gates but he personally
saved my company because when I was
struggling when I was making 300 bucks a
month when I couldn't survive in my
company when I didn't know what to do
when I said I quit on my partner because
I wasn't getting results for my company
after that worst day of my life I woke
up the next day and said you know what
somebody has solved this somebody's
figured out how to sell software I'm not
the first guy in the world to try to
sell software who's already done this
and how could I model that success and
so I looked at Bill Gates and how did he
make his first million dollars and I
applied that strategy for him was
partnerships and within a couple weeks
had my first deal with thirteen and a
half thousand dollars and that was that
was gold to me that was insane money for
me at the time and more importantly I
had a method to continue to make more
money for more partnerships bring that
more into my company and I learned that
just by reading his story by all of the
struggle and energy and effort that Bill
Gates went to to build Microsoft here's
a strategy that worked for him I can
learn from that and immediately apply to
my company and start seeing some results
it was crazy and so it's how I
approached every new problem that I
don't know how to solve instead of just
trying to come up with every genius idea
myself
look at who's already solved it and
apply it to my situation now it'll
always need some tweaks the way it
worked for Bill Gates is not the exact
way that it works for me but he took me
90% of the way I just had to figure out
that last 10% instead of trying to
figure out the entire hundred and so
whatever challenge you have in front of
you whatever it is whether it's I want
to launch a YouTube channel whether it's
I'm trying to figure out how to turn my
side hustle into a full-time business
whether it's I'm trying to build a
better relationship whatever problem is
in front of you you are not the first
person to go through this millions of
people have gone through this
learn their stories whether it's reading
the biography whether it's watching the
top 10 video whether it's listening to a
podcast whatever form you like to learn
best from I like video I like I'm a
visual person so that's why I make so
many videos for this channel whatever
the format you like learning most go out
find the people who have done it learn
from their strategies try it tweak it
for yourself and solve the problem and
then move on to the next one and try
that make that your default template
whenever you are faced with a problem
that you do not know how to solve yes
you want to bring your own creativity
and ingenuity to it and you want to look
at who's already solved this problem
because it will shortcut your path to
solving it so I have a special bonus
clip for you guys so before getting to
it I have a question of the day for you
which is what is one thing that you have
modeled from somebody else and I've had
lots of success with I'm really curious
to hear from you please leave it down
the comments below thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is I'll see
you again tomorrow morning for another
shot of espresso and enjoy the bonus
[Music]
neither one of us knew the business true
we knew so little about the variety
store business that we had to take the
book that was written by Ben Franklin
and apply the principles and apply the
controls the and the merchandise
merchandising programs that the outline
for us but of course knowing you and
knowing I myself a little bit we added
on didn't we
that's that's exactly right but we were
Mavericks even then and we were started
doing strange things like cranking up
ice-cream machines on the sidewalk on
Saturday night pop popcorn on the other
end of the sidewalk Hawking anything we
get a Hong Kong that looked like it
might have a chance to sell wherever it
made an easy life actually we've worked
hard that's right but but it gave us a
vehicle to to ride on that's right
exactly without without having to buy
merchandise
you know ourselves all the time or
distribution centers not having to do
the thing we'd had to do when we built
Walmart but I also grew up watching
people like Paul McCartney you know and
and and what Michael did for performing
in general is that's I think that's what
you're talking about it's like stage
performance on stage why we really fell
in love with Michael it was because he
he just like it wasn't even about
captivating you like he did something to
you blood when he performed on stage um
but there was always a thing about him
on stage where you like you can't touch
that yeah like you can't you can't
that's what made it so that's what made
it so grandiose and then you mix that
with people like Paul McCartney who have
you seen him race enough I'm so much
like 70 yeah I thought the Grammys when
they did okay the guys like 70 any plays
for like three hours
stadiums any and it's like you feel like
you're in his living room and he the
only pause between songs is like so he
can put a different guitar on or you
know get down on the piano and he talks
but he has people laughing in the crowd
and and so when you think about those
two
sides of being onstage that's what I
grew up yeah idolizing so that's
something that I've always wanted to
incorporate so when you go you know when
it's about you know sound like senorita
mm-hmm it's like I only want to play the
end of the song because this is a song
everybody can sing to each other and you
can feel like you know it feels like a
black party all of a sudden and so those
are always the two things that I'll know
that I was able to pick on pick up on
when I was younger like those are my
favorite too and they're both on the
opposite ends of the spectrum when you
really break it down like that but those
are my two favorite things to do at a
show is to make people go like damn yeah
and then to make people go like you know
what I'm having fun yeah you know like
those two things we try to play like
miles from Trailer Charlie Parker like
Patti LaBelle and you can when you come
out of that there's ten different people
and your personality is going to finally
come transcend to not transcend that
butBut morph into its own personality
because it's it is a personality and if
you have traveled roads of all the great
people but I think that happens with
anything it's a camera man you know you
look at the Saguaro whatever you know
all your favorite people and and and and
just deal with just the best or like
classical composers or whatever them or
people that deal with drama you know
what their elements drama they can say
all do it a different way and and jump
into it jump all over it I'm serious you
know just don't be bashful jump into it
try to copy it just like it is I mean I
mean I'm not you can't do this on a
professional level I mean in training
your mind you know to think on that
level the highest level go with
everybody from Johnny Williams a
goldsmith you know to Alan Silvestri you
know Stanley Stanley Clarke everybody
raise your standard Apple at the core is
core value
is that we believe that people with
passion can change the world not one
drop of myself work depends on your
acceptance of me I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual Clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details